[SPEAKER_00]: Paul Rivero awakens the next day after finding the letters in the secret lab and thinks about what he wants to do.
[SPEAKER_00]: It is 11 a.m.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I'm fully healed up and all that?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, you have all your hit points.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_01]: I guess I'll get up and look for Jamis and Miss Jamis.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you get up and walk through the palace, ignored as you usually are.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nothing special.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, nothing special.
[SPEAKER_00]: The servants stay out of your way but are, you know, polite to you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_00]: As you go down and do you want to just basically go to the residence of Lord Jamis?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you walk out into the streets of the Royal District and walk without being molested down the hill towards the residence of Lord Jamis.
[SPEAKER_00]: Basically, the guards look at you because you're rarely outside the royal palace.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, they know exactly who you are and they give you a wide berth, nod to you, and allow you to pass through both gates without any problem.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_00]: You walk up to the smaller palace of Lord Jamis, which is still a very impressive residence.
[SPEAKER_00]: In fact, I wouldn't say it's the second most impressive residence.
[SPEAKER_00]: There are very powerful merchants that live in the city.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, it is one that is probably most strategically positioned to overlook the bay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Which is Lord Jamis's domain.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's the harbormaster of Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: And he is responsible for keeping security going on there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Very important job, and he's also the admiral, so he has quick access to the docks, quick access to the royal docks, and his residence actually has a private road that goes down to the harbor district from where you're at.
[SPEAKER_00]: Anyway, the day is clear and pretty.
[SPEAKER_00]: A little hot for you, but it's okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you find yourself at the entrance to the residence
[SPEAKER_00]: So you come up to it and knock on the door.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you knock on the palace door.
[SPEAKER_00]: And the porthole opens up and a servant looks out and says to you, What can I help you with, sir?
[SPEAKER_01]: I need to speak to Lord Jamis and Miss Jamis.
[SPEAKER_01]: Please.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you have an appointment?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I don't.
[SPEAKER_00]: It seems strange that you come calling in the morning on the great Lord Jamis and have no reason to say who you are.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can I ask who's calling?
[SPEAKER_00]: Paul Rivera.
[SPEAKER_00]: Paul Rivero John?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Please wait here, sir.
[SPEAKER_00]: He closes the door.
[SPEAKER_00]: You can detect a hint of fear in his voice as he shuts the door.
[SPEAKER_00]: He shuts the portal.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Weird.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, you wait.
[SPEAKER_00]: Not long.
[SPEAKER_00]: Maybe about five minutes.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then he comes back and the door opens and he says, Please, sir.
[SPEAKER_00]: Follow me.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now, I have a question for you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Are you bringing the letters?
[SPEAKER_01]: I am bringing the letters.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: What about the book?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm not bringing the book.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: The homunculus... You want to read that later.
[SPEAKER_01]: That thing stays with me.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: The letters come.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, he takes you through a couple of hallways, and... Have I never been to...
[SPEAKER_00]: Long ago, I mean, you don't, you know, you've been here before, but it's not like you make a point to come to this place, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: He leads you into a study, and sitting at a table, well-pointed table with wines, cheeses, fruits,
[SPEAKER_00]: Is this older woman?
[SPEAKER_00]: I would say she's probably in her 70s.
[SPEAKER_00]: 60s, mid-60s, 70s.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is about the age of Lord Jamis.
[SPEAKER_00]: They're around the same age, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Obviously, at one time, she was beautiful.
[SPEAKER_00]: But, you know, time... She's that old.
[SPEAKER_00]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_00]: Time has taken away her looks.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, her hair... Is this Miss Jamis?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, this is Lady Jamis.
[SPEAKER_00]: Her hair is kind of a combination of white and red streaks, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: So you could tell that at one point she was a redhead.
[SPEAKER_00]: And she is Suel, okay?
[SPEAKER_00]: So Lord Jamis, actually, who is an Oeridian, was married to Lady Jamis, who was Suel.
[SPEAKER_00]: Normally, this kind of a marriage is very uncommon.
[SPEAKER_00]: Instantly, you realize that what this means is if this woman is
[SPEAKER_00]: Present in this scene.
[SPEAKER_00]: You've noticed in the past.
[SPEAKER_00]: You knew it in the past.
[SPEAKER_01]: It just now occurred to me.
[SPEAKER_01]: You realize what this means.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so anyway, you walk in and she basically stands and she says, Please, Paul, join me.
[SPEAKER_00]: And she motions to a very comfortable-looking, well-appointed chair, which, you know, you've seen many of in your day.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's not like this is.
[SPEAKER_00]: But she's affording you the amenities that your station deserves.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: She sits down and she says,
[SPEAKER_00]: Please leave us, she says to her maidservant.
[SPEAKER_00]: And she goes, and please, Paul and I wish to have a private conversation.
[SPEAKER_00]: Please close the door behind us.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right, so he walks out of the room and the door shuts.
[SPEAKER_00]: And Lady Jamis sits down and says,
[SPEAKER_00]: I am flattered that you have come to give me an audience, even though this is somewhat unexpected.
[SPEAKER_00]: I hope that my offerings to you are amenable to someone of your station, Paul.
[SPEAKER_01]: I am sorry for coming unannounced and on such short notice, but I have come up with information that I must ask you about.
[SPEAKER_01]: I assume it's very urgent for you.
[SPEAKER_01]: It is very important for me.
[SPEAKER_01]: I have been going through things of my mother, Alaria, and her possessions, and I have found... By the way, my condolences for her death.
[SPEAKER_00]: I thought Lady Alaria was very kind.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've had several conversations with her over the years.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've found her to be most amenable.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm sorry for your loss.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's greatly appreciated.
[SPEAKER_01]: But I have come with news and reason to believe that you are my grandmother.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, well, that seems to be a very interesting... You have a son named Grayson.
[SPEAKER_00]: I had a son named Grayson.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, unfortunately we lost Grayson many years ago.
[SPEAKER_01]: You think Grayson is your father?
[SPEAKER_01]: These letters prove that he was writing to my mother.
[SPEAKER_01]: You just flopped them down right on the table.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: And she's like, she looks at them,
[SPEAKER_00]: Do an insight check.
[SPEAKER_00]: Your insight is plus zero, but I want you to do an insight check.
[SPEAKER_00]: Eleven.
[SPEAKER_00]: To her, you can tell that she is actually kind of scared at what she's seeing.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_00]: And... She says...
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, the rumors are true.
[SPEAKER_00]: You do get right to the point, don't you, Paul?
[SPEAKER_00]: Some would call it impolitic, but I see it's refreshing.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do another insight check.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ooh, okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: You don't really know how to take that.
[SPEAKER_00]: You have a hard time navigating the niceties of sort of the courtly conversations, but she could be trying to say something to you.
[SPEAKER_00]: You don't really know what it is, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: But it's obvious you've rattled her in a way.
[SPEAKER_00]: And she says, and what did the letters say, Paul?
[SPEAKER_01]: Read them for yourself.
[SPEAKER_00]: I will.
[SPEAKER_00]: She takes her time.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, that's right.
[SPEAKER_00]: And the minutes go by.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you can tell that she is pouring over every word.
[SPEAKER_00]: Probably about halfway through the ten or so minutes when she's reading, she starts to cry.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you're a little lost on why, but her tears do hit the letters, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: It's been many years, many years since I've seen Grayson's handwriting, Paul.
[SPEAKER_00]: Understandable.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: He wrote to me when he went to
[SPEAKER_00]: Gradsul, those many years ago.
[SPEAKER_00]: Not as often, apparently, as he wrote to your mother, Aleria.
[SPEAKER_00]: But I cherish those letters, and reading these has brought me back to that time and how I miss him.
[SPEAKER_00]: I do consider this a gift for you allowing me to read them.
[SPEAKER_01]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_00]: It is obvious that he and Elyria were greatly in love.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Something that was kept a secret in the court.
[SPEAKER_01]: You didn't know of this?
[SPEAKER_01]: I had my suspicions.
[SPEAKER_00]: And to be honest with you, Paul, I have suspected in the past the possibility of you being my grandson.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, I hesitated to reach out to you.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't mean to be rude when I say this, but in all honesty,
[SPEAKER_00]: When you were born, I was waiting to see how you would grow and discern whether or not there were any aspects that would tell me whether or not you were Grayson's son.
[SPEAKER_00]: After your accident,
[SPEAKER_00]: I wouldn't be able to tell.
[SPEAKER_00]: The disfigurement that you had was so great that your lineage would be a mystery to me.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, I decided to leave it be, to avoid the scandalous... Not to avoid any scandal brought upon my family, but to avoid
[SPEAKER_00]: Reopening that wound.
[SPEAKER_00]: And honestly, the schism this may have created between Lord Jamis, my husband, and your father, it was a risk that I couldn't take unless I knew for certain that you were related to me.
[SPEAKER_00]: That you were Grayson's son indeed.
[SPEAKER_00]: So Lord Jamis doesn't know?
[SPEAKER_00]: Lord Demas says, oh no.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: He has suspicions, as I do.
[SPEAKER_00]: But honestly, Paul, your mother, Grayson, and Archibald were all very fast friends.
[SPEAKER_01]: Who is Archibald?
[SPEAKER_00]: Archibald is my nephew and he was brought up in my house with Grayson.
[SPEAKER_00]: They were cousins.
[SPEAKER_00]: He, like yourself, was a bastard.
[SPEAKER_00]: But
[SPEAKER_00]: The lady that birthed him was a high noble from Port Tully.
[SPEAKER_00]: And Archibald was definitely a precocious young man, incredibly intelligent.
[SPEAKER_00]: My brother, Zafar Azane, brought him to me to bring up because he saw in the young man
[SPEAKER_00]: The potential to be a very great scholar.
[SPEAKER_00]: Zafar, my brother, was, and still is, very high in the magical academies in Keoland.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do an insight check.
[SPEAKER_00]: 19.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's something more to that story.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's something...
[SPEAKER_00]: That she is not telling you and in fact you can tell that this is really kind of a sore subject with her because she not only is hesitating the quivering of her mouth is something that even when she was discussing the fact that you're her grandson
[SPEAKER_00]: It's different.
[SPEAKER_00]: Something is going on with this concept of Archibald.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now, you may want to push it.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm not going to say no or do or not.
[SPEAKER_00]: But the truth is, I mean you're a pretty forthright guy.
[SPEAKER_00]: You've already kind of proven that.
[SPEAKER_00]: But you don't know if you want to make this worse.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, you know, and it's pretty, pretty impolitic to base, even, you know this, it's pretty impolitic this, you're something, you're not telling me, you're lying to me.
[SPEAKER_00]: You know what I mean?
[SPEAKER_00]: It would be better to pick it out in a different way.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm debating if I want to let this go or not.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, you've already got a huge amount of information.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: But, you know, continue the conversation the way you want.
[SPEAKER_01]: So what happened to Grayson?
[SPEAKER_01]: These letters were 23 years ago.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you could please tell me.
[SPEAKER_01]: I want to know what happened to him.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know for sure.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, this last letter, regarding the alchemy caves, it gives me some insight.
[SPEAKER_00]: My brother, Zafar, has kept from me
[SPEAKER_00]: The true circumstances surrounding Grayson's death.
[SPEAKER_00]: But I believe I know what happened.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, how much do you know of the magnum opus?
[SPEAKER_00]: Everybody knows the Magnum Opus.
[SPEAKER_00]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_00]: You know the original text.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Actually, you don't.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, in truth, the Magnum Opus that we see today and we read has been edited by the Office of Rhythm Magic in Gradsul for hundreds of years.
[SPEAKER_00]: I can imagine.
[SPEAKER_00]: That kind of sounds...
[SPEAKER_00]: There is an original text, however, in the dungeons of the Office of Urban Magic.
[SPEAKER_00]: Archibald was obsessed with the knowledge contained there.
[SPEAKER_00]: And from these letters it's obvious to me that he enlisted Grayson's help in trying to find it.
[SPEAKER_00]: This endeavor, however, would be incredibly dangerous because the office of Brynn Magic is defended by the inquisitors of Gradsul.
[SPEAKER_00]: Powerful wizards who protect these tomes with magical, powerful magical wards and devices.
[SPEAKER_00]: There was a scandal years ago
[SPEAKER_00]: That involved Archibald Fryon.
[SPEAKER_00]: This Archibald that you speak of.
[SPEAKER_00]: And he was banished from the Magical Academies.
[SPEAKER_00]: And at the time also,
[SPEAKER_00]: My brother, Zafar Hussain, who was the head of the Office of Forbidden Magic, lost his post.
[SPEAKER_00]: Zafar was at the head of it?
[SPEAKER_00]: He's been many things.
[SPEAKER_00]: He once ran the transmutation school in grad school.
[SPEAKER_00]: But I believe he was head of the Office of Forbidden Magic when this scandal occurred.
[SPEAKER_00]: Zafar has hinted to me that your father died in the transmutation, in the alchemy caves underneath the transmutation school, trying to seek the magnum opus with Archibald Frihon.
[SPEAKER_00]: Archibald Frihon, put my son and your father
[SPEAKER_00]: In a very dangerous position.
[SPEAKER_00]: He was...
[SPEAKER_00]: He convinced Grayson to perform treason against the kingdom of Keoland.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now, Zafar has never told me whether or not the inquisitors of the school killed
[SPEAKER_00]: Grayson.
[SPEAKER_00]: Or if he was killed by the Magical Guardians in the Office of Public Magic.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, after the occurrence, Archibald Frihon, who was able to escape unscathed, no doubt abandoned... Archibald is alive?
[SPEAKER_00]: Or I'm safe until... Well, he was banished.
[SPEAKER_00]: To the province of Salinwar, after this occurred.
[SPEAKER_00]: Zafar Hussain lost his position at the Office of Forbidden Magic, and the head of the Transmutation School, a man named Edean Naqan, and a good friend of Zafar, lost his position as well at the Transmutation School.
[SPEAKER_00]: It was a scandal.
[SPEAKER_00]: That the nephew of the Office of Forbidden Magic would try to do such treason.
[SPEAKER_00]: Where had they gotten the knowledge?
[SPEAKER_00]: Obviously they had gotten it from Zafar Zayn himself.
[SPEAKER_00]: He had given the secrets to his nephews and told them tales about the Magnum Opus and the secrets that it contains.
[SPEAKER_00]: Basically, he inflamed their interest in these ancient times.
[SPEAKER_00]: And the knowledge that has been kept from the world.
[SPEAKER_01]: Where can I find Zafar?
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you wish to meet Zafar?
[SPEAKER_00]: That could be difficult.
[SPEAKER_00]: As you know, we are in a difficult situation with Keoland right now.
[SPEAKER_00]: The tensions between our two countries is great and in fact their navy is currently blocking the trade routes to Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: Zafar, my brother, serves the Duke of Gradsul, the man that is initiating the blockade.
[SPEAKER_00]: Zafar is doing his utmost to make sure that he can resolve the situation diplomatically but
[SPEAKER_00]: This will be difficult.
[SPEAKER_00]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, I would ask...
[SPEAKER_00]: However, I would say that
[SPEAKER_00]: I can try to contact him and tell him that you wish to meet him.
[SPEAKER_00]: Would you be willing to travel to Gradsul?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, definitely.
[SPEAKER_00]: Really?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: It would be dangerous at this time.
[SPEAKER_00]: Obviously you would have to ask your uncle if that would be possible.
[SPEAKER_00]: It will be done.
[SPEAKER_00]: I doubt he will let you go.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you intend to show him these?
[SPEAKER_00]: Would you like me to?
[SPEAKER_00]: She kind of looks at you.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll leave that to your judgment, but I will let you know that this will cause
[SPEAKER_00]: Difficulties between Lord Jamis and Prince Jeon.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, in all honesty, it may be a relief to your uncle.
[SPEAKER_00]: And she puts the letters down in front of you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Thank you for your time.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think your uncle was worried that Archibald Fryhon was actually your father.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll let him explain himself to you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Wait, what was that last part?
[SPEAKER_00]: I believe that your uncle was worried that Archibald Fryhon was actually your father.
[SPEAKER_00]: How do you think that?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, as I told you, your mother, Grayson, and Archibald were all close friends.
[SPEAKER_00]: You have to understand that Archibald, Grayson, your mother, and your uncle grew up in the royal palace together as children.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I believe that Prince Jeon and Archibald Fryhon did not get along.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can I ask you where you got these letters?
[SPEAKER_01]: I moved back into my mother's old room.
[SPEAKER_01]: I found them in a chest.
[SPEAKER_00]: In her room?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: She stands up and walks over to a library shelf.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: There are books all over the place in here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh man, that's going to be Harry Potter.
[SPEAKER_00]: And she basically moves one of the bookcases.
[SPEAKER_00]: And there's a door.
[SPEAKER_00]: She says to you, I picked this room for a reason, Paul.
[SPEAKER_00]: This door, and she puts her hand on it, once served as a passage between the primary admiral of the principalities and the prince, Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: There were secret meeting rooms in between these chambers.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, I know that it was used by Grayson and Archibald
[SPEAKER_00]: To fraternize with your sister.
[SPEAKER_00]: This door, and she puts her hand against it, has been locked by an arcane spell.
[SPEAKER_00]: And therefore cannot be picked by normal means.
[SPEAKER_00]: It has to be opened magically.
[SPEAKER_00]: There is a keyword associated with opening the door, which I do not know.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I have not brought myself to pass through this chamber, to this doorway, since the death of Grayson.
[SPEAKER_00]: There are secrets there that I did not want to intrude upon with your mother, Grayson, and the others.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, what I would say to you is, this library, feel free to use it any time.
[SPEAKER_00]: Most of the books here, there are not many of them, but most of the books here contain more interesting knowledge than what you will find in the Royal Library.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've selected what I would say the edge of knowledge.
[SPEAKER_00]: The corners that are more interesting contain difficult but true histories of what has happened.
[SPEAKER_00]: And the Flyn S. over the last thousand years.
[SPEAKER_00]: If you can figure out a way to open this door from the other side, you have complete access.
[SPEAKER_00]: If, however, you just wish to visit me, you can come here whenever you wish as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I will get a message to Zafar about you and tell him that you are curious.
[SPEAKER_01]: And where do I need to go to meet him?
[SPEAKER_01]: It's Keoland?
[SPEAKER_00]: We'll let him determine where.
[SPEAKER_00]: Zafar is a busy man and who knows, he may surprise you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright, thank you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_00]: She comes to basically say, do you want to embrace me?
[SPEAKER_00]: She holds her hands out like that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you feel any kind of reason to do that or is it just a little too...
[SPEAKER_00]: Embrace?
[SPEAKER_00]: She wants to give you a hug.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_00]: Because you're the grandma, she's your grandmother.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: It'll probably be an awkward hug, but...
[SPEAKER_00]: Roll the charisma check.
[SPEAKER_00]: We're going to see just how awkward this hug is.
[SPEAKER_00]: What if I roll a nat 20?
[SPEAKER_00]: It'll be an 18!
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh my god, I got an 18.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, a 16.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: You hug, and actually you do it in a way that is genuine.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're not awkward, at least.
[SPEAKER_00]: And she kind of reciprocates, and you can tell she sobs a little bit.
[SPEAKER_00]: As you do that, you can tell that she is, you know, genuinely touched by your acceptance of her and kind of relieved from all of the weirdness that has occurred there, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: And she opens the door and basically is hiding her face when she says, please, try Don.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's the servant, the guy that brought you in.
[SPEAKER_00]: Please show Paul out.
[SPEAKER_00]: And she's trying to hide her face, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: So he tried on bows, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: And says, please, sir, come this way.
[SPEAKER_00]: You begin walking out.
[SPEAKER_00]: Roll perception.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do I have perception?
[SPEAKER_01]: No?
[SPEAKER_00]: What'd you roll?
[SPEAKER_00]: Seven.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: The two of you walk out towards the door and I'd say probably it's around 1 p.m. and he shows you out and says, Sir.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: What do you do?
[SPEAKER_01]: Sir, thank you.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're welcome.
[SPEAKER_00]: You detect a strange accent on this person.
[SPEAKER_00]: And actually, you look at him and realize, as you're leaving, just how big this guy really is.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I'm not saying that he's, like, huge and bulky.
[SPEAKER_00]: But he has broad shoulders, and he seems to be about six foot four.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, not, like, girthy like there are a lot of, you know, warriors that are
[SPEAKER_00]: Big, burly, whatever.
[SPEAKER_00]: This guy seems a little more sleek, and his movements are akin to that of a big cat, like a cougar or tiger.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do I think he's an assassin?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, not necessarily, but he's not wearing armor or carrying any weapons, but you realize that you would be
[SPEAKER_00]: You wouldn't want to fuck with him.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's basically what it all comes down to.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's not just a normal manservant.
[SPEAKER_00]: He obviously is... Do I see his face?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh yeah, you see his face.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's Oeridian, too.
[SPEAKER_00]: Jet black hair.
[SPEAKER_00]: Black eyes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright, cool.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is obviously not just a manservant.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is Lady Janice's bodyguard.
[SPEAKER_00]: Big boy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, well, uh, I bounce.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you walk out of there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Where do you want to go?
[SPEAKER_01]: Um...
[SPEAKER_01]: I guess we gotta go find Jeon now.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, you take your letters.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you go back to the royal palace.